at the uk has surpassed 100
deaths within 28 days of a positive
coronavirus test and horrific
milestone and not just an abstract
number but behind
every single one of those numbers is a
family grieving
the loss of a loved one today 1631
deaths have been recorded and that
taking the uk
over that 100 000 mark it is a figure
that far
exceeds most of the worst case scenario
estimates made
at the start of the pandemic let's go
live to the newsroom
let's speak to our health correspondent
ashish joshi a hundred thousand
deaths arshish this is a significant
moment that no one wanted to reach
absolutely this is unimaginable
when you think just a little over 12
months ago
as we were entering into the pandemic
and there were these warnings from
the prime minister and government
scientists about just where
this pandemic would go we were talking
about
figures in their hundreds and then in
their thousands i don't think anyone
then could have predicted that we would
be reporting today
100 000 deaths here in the uk
it is one of the worst hit countries in
the world by
any measure i know time and time again
people look at data and they say well if
you look at the population if you look
at this
that this is just a very simple stark
number
it's a hundred thousand people who have
lost their lives
because of covid and that means there
will be 100 000
families in mourning grieving for their
loved ones when the prime minister
mentioned that we would be fighting this
pandemic
and that lives would be lost he was
flanked by his
scientific advisors and and the chief
medical officer and they
warned that there would be deaths in
their thousands
but to be here now talking about 100 000
people
it's really the second wave which is uh
proved so costly in terms of lives that
the speed at which
these deaths have multiplied since
october we've been seeing
the numbers of people catching
coronavirus being admitted to hospital
and then of course if you're in hospital
the chances are that um
you you may die if you have underlying
health conditions or you're in one of
the higher age groups and then we've
been warned again
that the transmissibility of the variant
meaning more people were catching it
younger people were catching it
people were falling sicker it's the same
thing we've been told by doctors and
nurses
and medical staff in icus and hospitals
across the country it was there it was
happening but
like you said sarah this is the number
that nobody wanted to
report on today and we have passed that
grim milestone
100 000 deaths here in the uk